كمأ سافران بيلوغا الكافيار وبطاطس مانات
هي فقط بعض أغلى الأطعمة في العالم من
حيث وزن البطاطس.
المكان الوحيد الذي يمكنك فيه العثور على ملك
البطاطس ، الذي يحبه صاحب الجلالة ،
جبل القنبلة ، ولكن إذا كنت تريد أن
تأكلها طازجة ، فعليك أن تكون سريعًا
لأنها متوفرة فقط لمدة عشرة أيام في
السنة ، هذا هو رودي ، وهو مزارع بطاطس ،
فما الذي يجعل  إن جزيرة نواندي الجوية
خاصة جدًا بالنسبة إلى هؤلاء Smuts ، قال del sur
meuse لإطعامنا للحصول على
[موسيقى] ممتازة ،
آه ، طفلة صغيرة حلوة هي طبيبة Anatole ،
ليس لدي أي فكرة عن من أنا فقط مكمل
لأنهم بالضبط في التعريف الجديد
لجميع المزارعين في  الجزيرة جزء
من التعاونية التي يقومون بها في التعامل مع
بيع مواد التنظيف وإرسالها إلى جميع أنحاء
أوروبا.
فويلا
آسف مرحبًا آلية ميرا الهشة
sipoc Saco do sombrio de l'homme c'est
la la la أنا أسميت حلب وليست صوفي لا
الهولندية ديلان العمة صوفي فريدة
من نوعها معظم الجوهرة الآن آمل أن تكون
جالسًا لأنه في عام 1996 هذه البطاطا باهظة الثمن
جلب المزاد مبلغًا مجنونًا ،
لحسن الحظ بالنسبة لي ، فإن البطاطس ذات غطاء محرك السيارة في الوقت الحاضر
لن تكسر البنك
وتجلب أكثر من 5 دولارات للرطل الذي
لا يزال كثيرًا مقابل كيس من البطاطس يبحر
عند الطلب الشهي ،
انظر في انسجام تام  المجموع ليس لدى الشيطان
حرفي ، فهم ليسوا شريك سيولة
غير عادل منذ مهرجان جيون ،
آه لم يعد على طاولة شاي ألفونزو
ملحمة - أبولو أنت سوف نتوقف عن
الظهور وأنت لا تظهر أمامك فهي وفيرة جدًا
بمجرد اكتمال الحصاد سنويًا.
يقام المهرجان هنا ،
يتم تقديم البطاطس الذهبية تقليديًا مع
السردين المشوي ، لذا يمكنك الاستمتاع بتذوق
السوبرانو في بانديتا.
o menos
moshpit emoji القرص الأصلي في Napa
Hankou dzasta يطاردني إذا تم تنفيذ الإجراء ،
لقد سمعت كل
ذلك بشكل جماعي ، لذلك لدينا
ملك البطاطس ، شكرًا لك
صاحب الجلالة
[الموسيقى]